Tyler's with us in Fresno hi Tyler how
are you hey how's it going mr. Angie
better than I deserve what's up all
right so I'm a senior in high school
right now and I'm actually taking a
financial literacy class cool through an
ROP program and I recently just got
accepted into UCLA mm-hmm but my family
and where I am at right now I won't be
able to afford it unless I get student
loans so I mean I know you say like
because my teacher actually uses a lot
of your principles in teaching about
credit cards and how it's like it's
better to let one money aside to save
than to go through the hassle of having
to pay off these credits and possibly
getting into more and more debt so I was
wondering how do you think I should go
about getting a student mug we're paying
off school this 32,000 here
approximately gotcha okay and do you
have any money at all um I do have some
but it won't be much after the first
couple of semesters how much money do
you have
it's about 40 okay
okay all right good good so I get you
through a year yeah okay that's good
we're just going there for about four
years
yeah I was planning that I knew that I
know UCLA was a four-year school and so
what do you plan on studying
I plan on studying Aeronautics and jet
propulsion
okay good I know they have a very good
space program there don't you oh okay
and if you looked at what your
curriculum looks like the first year
nowhere nowhere not X or Jet Propulsion
in your curriculum for the first year
yeah the first year is just gonna be a
lot of generalize that's I know I let me
straight up high school and then as well
as some aerospace dynamics and physics
yeah you'll pick up most of your things
specific to your field of study in your
junior and your senior year maybe a tiny
bit in your sophomore year your first
two years are primarily general studies
and most good degree fields okay
and that's pretty standard with most
four-year universities
okay there's two or three things to
think about number one
I'm never going to tell you to borrow
money hi you the 30 year old version of
you is gonna be pissed at the 18 year
old version of you if you go deeply in
debt to go to UCLA to get a degree in
jet propulsion this is not gonna turn
out well okay so let's just start with
the premise we're not gonna borrow money
now how in the world can we get through
four years of school with $40,000 if
we're not going to borrow money the
number one thing that causes people to
go in debt is their choice of school you
wisely have chosen an in-state school
however you can do one or maybe two
years of Community College get your
basics out of the way and in California
that's free free okay not what you
wanted to do you wanted to go to UCLA
move in the dorm play some beer pong on
the weekends but I'm wanting you to go
to Community College since you're a
broke guy I've been a broke guy I don't
want you to be a broker guy the second
thing I want you to consider is how much
work you can do between now and the next
five years and I'm not talking about
flopping whoppers at minimum wage I'm
talking about starting a real legitimate
small business idea or doing something
in the jet propulsion field or getting
into an apprentice program of some kind
or considering you know the military as
an option or something along these lines
to where someone gives you so much money
for working that you just work your way
through college and you can do that
especially with a $40,000 head start
okay because you got two years before of
work to build up the next $40,000 and
you can make that delivering pizzas now
you're not gonna have a party life
you're gonna be working dude I worked 40
to 60 hours a week when I was in college
and I did not die from it and I
graduated in four years most people work
while they're in college at least the
last three generations up until now now
people go now people go $150,000 in debt
and call it on the set
city and it's not a necessity okay so
where you go to school how you go to
school how much you work the next one is
I your new part-time job in addition to
your other job is applying for
scholarships I want you to apply for one
thousand scholarships in the coming 12
months I want you to scour the internet
for anything having to do with your race
creed color national origin your
heritage your jet-propulsion
scholarships Aeronautics scholarships
scholarships from American Airlines our
Boeing for people that want to because
they want people the sharp like you to
be ready to come into their field and
having studied it and if you will get a
turn down for nine hundred and fifty
scholarships and get fifty two thousand
dollar scholarships and you go to career
and you go to Community College for one
year for free or two years for free and
you work your butt off all the way
through school tada
you don't need alone it'll work now the
question is are you really going to do
that or you don't take what you think is
the easy way out which is a student loan
and you'll find out when you're thirty
it wasn't an easy way out
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]